[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute wird bei uns gegrillt und bei
vielen ist so dass ich sagen das machen
wir nur am wochenende
weil wir daran genug zeit dafür haben
grillen ist wirklich super ich liebe
grillen vor allem im sommer wenn man
draußen sitzen kann und man kann super
viel vorbereiten also für mich ist es
immer eigentlich gar keinen stress ich
kann auch vieles am abend vorrat
zubereiten wie zum beispiel gebackene
schafskäse oder die spieße die ganzen
väter aufstriche krems und tipps und was
ich dann noch frisch zubereitet ist
einfach nur noch der salat und hier in
dem fall tomate mozzarella
ich zeige euch heute in diesem video mal
die auswahl die es bei uns heute beim
grillen auf dem tisch gibt natürlich
auch das fleisch was später auf dem
tisch kommt und einfach wie ich jetzt
alles nacheinander vorbereite
zumal jetzt zuallererst mal ein
magisches parkett da findet ihr das
rezept hier verlinkt und das versuche
ich jetzt ganz kurz setzt den teig an
und dann kann er einfach den ganzen tag
über gehen schon erledigt und als
nächstes kann ich jetzt alles
vorbereiten was in den kühlschrank kann
jetzt bereite ich meine väter cremt so
dafür braucht ihr nur 2 basic zutaten
einmal frischkäse einmal fetakäse also
entweder schafskäse orientierten käse
dessen aus kuhmilch salz und pfeffer und
aus dieser creme kann man wirklich alles
mögliche machen was ihr aus dem
feinkostladen kennt das heißt ihr könnt
zum beispiel eine paprika väter creme
machen ihr könnt dabei auch getrocknete
tomaten peperoni dazugeben ananas alles
was ihr gerne
[Musik]
der käse wird jetzt kurz zerkleinert und
mit dem frischkäse salz und pfeffer
verrühren
salzgitter nicht so sehr denn der käse
ist ja schon 40
[Musik]
also eigentlich geht ja noch eine basic
zur tat so ist das bei mir knoblauch
aber da kommt gleich dazu
[Musik]
die cremes jetzt ein bisschen fester die
gehört aber so denn ich komme noch die
zusatz zutaten mit rein wie zum beispiel
paprika und etwas knoblauch
ich nehme es ihr den paprika den ich
bereits eingelegt habe da gibt es auch
bald das rezept dazu und ihr könnt
natürlich auch eine hohe paprika nehmen
und die hatte dann einen hohen
wasseranteil und dadurch wird die creme
dann ein bisschen flüssiger also die
pipe habe ich ein gelegt kurz
zerkleinern und dann mit der creme
verrühren
[Musik]
die kann ich jetzt schon mal umfüllen
und mit der zweite portion da kommen
dann auch getrocknete tomaten reihen
etwas peperoni und nochmal sind chili
[Musik]
und hier gebe ich jetzt für die farbe
und den geschmack noch ein bisschen
tomatenmark dazu
[Musik]
da könnt ihr euch total kreativ sein
aber ich habe jetzt zwei richtig geniale
gips gemacht aus zwei grundzutaten ich
mag auch aufstriche und selbst den
bisschen süßlich sind durch feige
aprikosenmarmelade und da passt dann
könne zum beispiel wunderbar dazu
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt noch tomate und
mozzarella kleingeschnitten einfach in
scheiben geht doch echt ganz fix und
dann mache ich jetzt einfach eine tomate
mozzarella salat den mögen wir auch ganz
gerne und ich finds auch immer schön
wenn die mini mozzarella geschnitten
wird dann ein bisschen balsamico creme
darüber mag ich lieber als balsam essig
bisschen olivenöl salz umfeld ball kommt
zum schluss und jetzt kommt auch
basilikum dazu das hole ich schnell
draußen vom kräuter hochbeet
[Musik]
da stehen sie glücklich der basilikum
ist richtig schön gewachsen
ich glaube du schon sagst den moral nie
gesagt hat naja ich denke ich das ganze
abkommen den kühlschrank und dann machen
wir gleich das nächste rezept jetzt gibt
es noch einen gebackenen schafskäse den
mache ich auch ganz gerne im backofen da
gibt es auch schon ein video dazu wir
machen das ganze jetzt in dem iphone und
daneben auch auf dem grill
dafür nehme ich den fast gereiften käse
der ist nämlich wunderbar würzig
schmeckt super lecker und moritz ist
auch recht fan davon und ich auch ich
lese kann man jetzt hier eingeben und
dann noch ein bisschen gemüse kräuter
dazugeben
[Musik]
die zwiebel viertele ich jetzt gemeinsam
mit den tomaten und gibt sie über den
käse der knoblauch wird jetzt noch in
scheiben geschnitten und dann kommen
noch die oliven peperoni der rosmarin
salz pfeffer und das olivenöl dazu den
rosmarin hochbeet jetzt kann die
vorspeise abgedeckt werden und auch in
den kühlschrank
bei uns gibt es später auch
süßkartoffeln vom grill und dazu passt
perfekt eine guacamole das genaue rezept
findet ihr auch bei meinem süßkartoffel
pommes und ich nehme da immer eine reihe
far ocado dann kommt der kern heraus
manchmal wir da nicht raus dann
eigentlich drauf und dann einfach mit
dem löffel aus krapfen und ich mache
immer gerne knoblauch mit reinen das
chili limettensaft manchmal auch noch
eine charlotte also eine kleine zwiebel
sind salz und pfeffer und dann ist
dieser brauch schon fertig
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es noch eine kräuterbutter
dafür kleinere ich jetzt einfach die
kräuter geben bisschen muße dazu salz
und pfeffer knoblauch als ich jetzt mal
weg ist und es wird alles zu knoblauch
lastig und dann zeige ich euch nur mal
die kräuterbutter richtig schön
anrichten kann
[Musik]
ich habe zwei kühlakkus aus dem geschäft
da kommt morten ritter drauf und ein
backshop hier gibt nämlich die
kräuterbutter und die kommt in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen stern töne
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich immer teil der tops auf
das backpapier spritzen und habe dann
einfach schöne kleine portionen
[Musik]
und die gebe ich jetzt so in den
kühlschrank ihr könnt aber auch
einfrieren und dann wenn sie gefroren
sind einfach schön verpacken und hab
dann jederzeit kräuterbutter schönen
hübschen portionen auf vorrat
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich noch mal ein baguette
fertig und im prinzip habe ich dann fast
alles schon fertig das fleisch das mache
ich dieses mal nicht wenn ihr das
marinieren wollt müsst ihr das natürlich
auch vorher noch machen im kühlschrank
stellen so dass eben alles gleichzeitig
bereit ist ich liebe dieses baguette
weil man nichts kneten und formen muss
und das kriegt es jeder muss nur warten
ist der teig aufgeht
und ab mit ihren den ofen und nicht
denkt hausnetz den tischen
[Musik]
werden die jungs und mädels hinter mir
jetzt noch den tisch decken kann ich
schon mal ein paar sachen auf den grill
schmeißen
da grinst richtig heiß schon wenn die
süßkartoffel groß sind können dass er im
backofen organ oder einfach auf dem
grill eine stunde lang grillen
bevor ihr eben alles andere macht hier
habe ich jetzt keine schafskäse die
zucchini kann mich jetzt auch schon mal
drauf legen
die habe ich in scheiben geschnitten da
kann man hier alles schon mal
vorbereiten und die aubergine auch drauf
legen die soll schönweiß werden und
gleich danach die champignons
[Musik]
salat kann man jetzt auch welche
anmachen direkt am tisch und felder
nicht zusammen
[Musik]
bei der maschine erkennt man übrigens
ganz gut dass sie da ist wenn die schale
so schön braun wird also hier sieht man
noch schwarze flecken und hier ist er
schon richtig schön braun und dann ist
er innen auch richtig gut war
[Musik]
so unsere vorspeisen sind jetzt fertig
die hole ich gleich raus jetzt kommt
unser großes t bone steak drauf da gibt
es dann gleich meine barbecue sauce dazu
puzzle fertig erstellt und den werten
und schon mal öffnen
[Musik]
das team on stage jetzt noch ein
bisschen ziehen dann verteilt sich auch
das fleisch darf wieder schön und dann
soweit fertig später gibt's das her
[Musik]
ich bin ja so jemand ich es gerne die
ganzen beitragen und das vielleicht
vergesse ich meine beste aufgriff
[Musik]
so das fleisch habe ich jetzt gesetze
und quatsch und jetzt kommt da noch
cities barbecue sauce darauf natürlich
selbstgemacht und das einzige was wird
man machen ist wird nutzen noch die
restwärme vom grill da kommen gleich
bananen rein
die werden oben einmal angeschnitten
dann lege ich schokoladen sticks rein
wie zum beispiel herz schokolade
da kommt das ganze auf dem grill
schmilzt natürlich richtig schön in die
banane reihen die banane wird weich und
dann gibt es da eine kugel vanilleeis
bezogen ja ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat ihr seht jetzt so
grillen wir morath ist murat hat im
prinzip nur die aufgabe das fleisch auf
den grill zu schmeißen alles andere
bereite ich war
ich hoffe dass ich die rezeptideen
gefallen haben bei uns ist es nicht
jedes mal so also immer gibt's was
anderes mal gibt es kartoffelsalat
machen gibt's gurkensalat mal geht es
bunt gemischten salat ganz egal wie ich
hoffe euch gefällt die idee und ihr habt
ein paar tipps und tricks mitnehmen
können ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
grillen und wir sehen uns wieder das
nächste mal die butter ist dann
wahnsinnig cool
die kräuterbutter
[Musik]